personally I think every time is a
perfect time to start a business there's
no bad times if you do the work if you
do the preparation you'll know when it's
time and it doesn't mean that it won't
be a little bit scary but you know it's
you'll know and you don't have to quit
the daytime job if you don't feel that
all that comfortable and you can give it
a run at night but whatever works for
you now with the internet you've got all
the choices in the world and you can
just go out there do your own thing the
passion I've always had for business and
being an entrepreneur the trend that
transfers into the Mavs I've always been
passionate some people thought you know
it's a it's more OCD than anything else
which i think is a great trait for an
entrepreneur when I you know I mentioned
the stamp business I would stay up til
3:00 4:00 in the morning even though I
had to get up and go to school and read
Lin stamp news and Scots stamp journals
and have them all memorized and and use
that to give myself an edge even when I
was in college I'd be in live in the
library reading business books and just
looking for business biographies and
just reading all I could about business
when I had Micro solutions and you know
I started with no money
you know I pull all-nighters in front of
borrowed computers teaching myself
software and and how to program you just
watched two amazing clips with Mark
Cuban take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]